the barbaric murder of David Haines seen
here in the Balkans in 2003 is shocking
but not surprising in doing this our
office normally goes across to Belgrade
and actually meets the people so they
can gain trust from us
Islamic state fighters said they would
kill him in just 11 days after issuing
the threat to behead the 44 year old aid
worker they did news of the killing led
David Cameron to summons senior
ministers and advisers to an emergency
meeting of the Cobra Committee which he
chaired earlier he issued a statement he
said this is a despicable and appalling
murder of an innocent aid worker it's an
act of pure evil my heart goes out to
the family of David Haines who have
shown extraordinary courage and
fortitude throughout this ordeal the
world learned of this latest slaying in
a chillingly familiar manner a video
featuring this man standing beside his
hostage who identifies himself as David
Haines before being murdered Sky News is
not showing any of the moving footage
from the video but in an audio message
the man in black taunts the West your
evil alliance with America which
continues to strike the Muslims of Iraq
and most recently from the Haditha dam
will only accelerate war destruction
David Haines murderer appears to be the
same British man who beheaded two other
hostages in the past month there are
various identifying features that he
shares beyond the fact that he obviously
bears a striking resemblance from
between the three videos that we've now
seen but also when they look at his
hands and his eyebrows and do voice
analysis it's pretty clear that it is
the same guy American journalist James
Foley was the first Western hostage
whose murder was released on video by is
on August the 19th two weeks later
another American reporter steven sotloff
was decapitated and the footage uploaded
it was in that video that the extremists
threatened to kill David Haines next
Barack Obama spoke of his disgust saying
the United States
strongly condemns the barbaric murder of
UK citizen David Haynes by the terrorist
group ISIL our hearts go out to the
family of mr. Haynes and to the people
of the United Kingdom the United States
stands shoulder-to-shoulder tonight he
said with our close friend and Ally in
grief and resolve David Haynes was born
in England but brought up in Scotland
and lived with his second wife and the
youngest of his two daughters in Croatia
his brother released a statement saying
David was most alive and enthusiastic in
his humanitarian roles his joy and
anticipation for the work he went to do
in Syria is for myself and family the
most important element of this whole sad
affair he was and is loved by all his
family and will be missed terribly
hundreds of British men and some women
have travelled to Syria and Iraq to join
Islamic state and in the latest murder
video there is a threat to behead yet
another British hostage bill Bowden
spanked